so when can I start okay hi my name is
Ben frien I'm board member year in the
World Economic Forum and i'm chief
executive officer of africa listened
which is a technology company actually I
wish you would be here because you would
see a discussion that is very
undeveloped if you of the obvious
opinion that Davos is already for old
men in suits then walk around and talk
about power the discussion here is with
young people new entrepreneurs new ideas
new concepts and what I would like to
have is much more important come how we
can change the models in which we
operate the societies more less about
new ideas why is it young people always
have to ask permission to start
something why would we create an
environment in which is simply the next
thing to do